no one expects a five-star meal on a
mountain that's just crazy
so we went on a backpacking trip up in
the mountain the cold mountain I almost
got hypothermia I know I'm super sick we
have a lot of extra freeze-dried food so
we're just gonna do a little taste test
in case you didn't get enough of
rehydrated food last time is it all
there's on me well I'm vegetarian I
don't think I'm gonna do this see you
Jen
Shepard's potatoes do with be just from
looking at it I can't tell you exactly
where the beef is kinda looks like I
want it whoa it tastes like every food
from Thanksgiving dinner mixed into one
that is very salty right here right now
not stoked on it but if you were hiking
it'd probably be fine this reminds me of
the lunch ladies in movies who just
scooped up a big slap it and just throw
it on your plate
Louisiana red beans and rice I can
already smell it it smells very very
flavorful action you can't tell that
this was prepared in a bag just based on
appearances a little bit salty a little
bit peppery it seems like it's
rehydrated well actually so the texture
is fine it's pretty basic this is
straight-up just rice and beans this is
pretty feeling no I'd probably say
imagine if you're starving on a mountain
this is probably great you cannot tell
it was cooked in a bag either so props
to that Thai style
coconut curry with me will say that I'm
the most excited about this one because
it looks the most fun I see little flat
noodles which look interesting I see
broccoli and I see bits of beef again
smells like biryani
it smells like basically like rice and
spices it's very chewy I think this is
the best one this is definitely the
tastiest in terms of complexity of
flavor in the other dishes all the
flavors kind of ran together but in this
one you can taste like the individual
beef and the broccoli and the peppers
which is pretty nice it's not a you know
Michelin star but it's definitely fun no
one expects a five-star meal on a
mountain
I could definitely see these meals being
good nourishment after a long day's hike
its dehydrated food in a bag that you
put boiling water into and everything
tastes better on the mountain I probably
eat these again if I'm in the middle of
nowhere and I've just had a long hike I
want to eat as many carbs and as much
beef and potato as I can I would eat
camp foods that tasted terrible if it
meant they wouldn't attract bears
because [ __ ] bears